l'elysée montmartre qui sacrifiait à la
danse au théâtre au patent au début des
années 50
les français découvrent le catch
nous sommes à l'âge d'or du catch
français les combats de ce sport
spectacle originaires des etats unis se
multiplient à paris à l'elysée
montmartre au vel d'hiv ou au cirque
d'hiver
les rencontres sont même retransmises à
la télévision commentée par
l'emblématique roger couderc l'ange
blanc andré le géant le bourreau de
béthune ou encore l'affreux de l'apport
sont les stars de l'époque
ils font partie de la fédération
française de catch professionnel créé
dans les années 30
l'ange blanc voulez vous nous dire
pourquoi vous combattez masquer le coach
est un sport noble de l'anonymat je
viens pour le punit le méchant ses mises
en scène participent au succès du catch
et même si les spectateurs savent qu'ils
assistent à des combats parfaitement
orchestré le spectacle vaut le détour
ce regard derrière 4h et oui pourquoi
c'est un sport à la fois pour les
catcheurs fait pour le public parce que
il y en a autant sur le ring dans les
graves à l'époque des intellectuels
s'intéressent même au succès de ce
divertissement populaire
voici l'analyse de l'homme de lettres
roland barthes en 1957 la justice du
catch et une justice du paiement on en
vend après souvent le public crier fait
le payer il s'agit de faire payer le
[ __ ] mais l' enthousiasme pour cette
discipline ne suffisaient pas à rassurer
ce professionnel
ils s'inquiétaient pour l'avenir du
catch français le catch si nous les
vieux on n'en met pas des jeunes dans le
coup c'est à dire déjà des gars
courageux qui veulent bien apprendre le
cash va mourir faute de combattants des
craintes qui se vérifieront quelques
années plus tard dès le milieu des
années 70 le catch français a du mal à
se renouveler et l'engouement des
spectateurs c'est si la fédération
française de catch professionnel ne se
reformera qu'à partir de 2006 après plus
de 20 ans d'inactivité
[Musique]